thank you ah
happy people thank you i appreciate it
you can uh i know it
i love you too i know it's hard to
breathe in those masks that looks like
it will be ending soon
we have a reopening date here in
california
june 15th will all businesses at full
capacity as of june 15th and that's
probably because we have california here
the lowest coveted positivity rate
in the entire country but still number
one in herpes
so don't get down
so we are reopening and now comes the
hard part thinking of something to tell
all those people who you said
you know i really want to get together
when this is over
some sad news
i must report here from uh england uh
prince philip
queen elizabeth dude
uh shockingly dead at 99.
he died today yes he died as he lived
peacefully in his sleep
uh boy and i tell you
bitter about that harry thing to the end
his last words were i never bought megan
merkel as a lawyer on suits
[Laughter]
so uh matt gates is in the news do you
know matt gates
that he's a republican huge trumper from
uh florida if you don't know him
show the picture because everybody knows
no that's that's not the right picture
show the real
they do look a lot alike he always has
that look
oh sure the picture gets applause i mean
all my hard work
no that's matt always has that look on
his face like eat it nerd
but he's in big trouble if you heard
this he's allegedly accused of sex
trafficking sex with a minor and showing
nude pictures to the other guys at work
basically all the stuff you assumed
would be going on if no one had brought
this up
in his defense his job title is florida
representative
now i this is
but i tell you this guy did do some
sleazy things
that's not gay first of all he was
allegedly
giving ecstasy to these uh women and uh
you know republican ecstasy i have to
tell you is a little different
oh good they're catching on faster now
yes it is it's a lot you stay up all
night hugging the flag
and screwing poor people it's a little
different
so also the videos of nude women you
know
this is he had these he was showing them
around he showed one of a nude woman
with a hula hoop
and lindsey graham said i have never
seen anything like that
also is that a hula hoop
so different tonight okay so
uh but apparently matt gates listened to
this he asked before any of we knew any
of this he asked the trump white house
when
fatso was still in office if he could
have a blanket preemptive pardon
as as innocent people do
for any future crimes he didn't even
specify just a blanket pardon and donald
court donald trump today spoke out on
this he said uh
that is [ __ ] he said it is a total
fake news story everybody knows
that when i was in the white house all
legitimate requests for pardons had to
go through the kardashians
and
and and today it's in the news with matt
gates that uh it
was reported i don't know but that his
associate in this
endeavor with the young women uh is pled
not guilty but is going to change it to
guilty
uh and probably testify against matt
gates and say that matt gates
listen to this use venmo to send 900
to this guy who then sent the money to
the women
which ironically is one of the only
times that trickled down economics has
actually worked um
oh i can't i kid matt gates you know
what i think he's uh he's i think he
said about this he matt knows that
traveling a 17 year old girl
across state lines is wrong and he said
he regrets it
mainly because she played cardi b the
whole way
just he obviously didn't check if she
had id
thank god they didn't try to take her to
vote
there's a guy who gets it okay
but you know there are scandals on on
all sides uh
the daily mail is reporting that uh
biden's son hunter biden
had his own pornhub account where he
posted videos of him
having sex with two women at the same
time
i got to say this as hobbies go i'll
take this over trump's son's hunting
endangered species how about that
you